- Hey guys, welcome to Is This Okay,
where we talk about
things that are happening
in the world, wondering if, it's okay.
I'm Nyla.
- I'm Becky.
- I'm Daysha.
- I'm Morgan.
- I'm Kwesi.
- Yeah, Kwesi.
(giggling)
- I just realized it's like The View,
with a male guest.
- [All] Yeah.
- So today, we're gonna talk about
how do you separate the
person from their art,
when the person can
sometimes be problematic
in their life, but the work that they've
done is really important,
or something that's
very valuable.
What sparked this
discussion was Nate Parker,
and Birth of a Nation.
- You have Nate Parker, who
took this very important
slave revolt story, and so this is a very
monumental film for the black community.
But, 17 years ago, Nate
Parker was caught up
in a rape charge, allegation.
- I think he was acquitted
of rape, essentially.
- Yeah.
- 17 years ago.
- I think the reason why
the question or discussion
of today is more about
a broader scope of it,
is because with any one of
these particular things,
you never can know exactly for sure
if the person did it.
- It happened.
And this woman is not here anymore,
to talk about what happened.
And she's not here as a result
of that experience.
- He wrote a letter about that as well,
I think, showing empathy.
- He has not shown an ounce
of empathy.
He's just like, I'm not gonna say sorry,
it sucks that that happened to you,
or you think that's what happened to you,
but I'm not going to apologize.
I was leaning towards,
this film is important,
so like, I'll probably go see it.
And then I read the
article where he's like,
"I'm not sayin' sorry."
And I was like, well now I'm
all up in my feels again,
and I don't know how I feel.
(laughs)
- Well, I'm gonna go
see the movie for sure.
Nate Parker is not my friend,
you know, he's someone who
put something on screen,
that I think is important to see.
- Where do you personally
draw the line between,
I like your art, but
you're a shitty person?
What is considered
supporting, like I know people
who were like, "I don't turn
Chris Brown off in the car,
"if it's on the radio, but
I won't buy his albums."
- I'm like that with hip hop in general.
Like, for me, I'm not
going to pay for the music,
I'm not gonna give someone
money to take that money
and then oppress me, but,
if it's there, like I'm
not gonna throw a hissy fit about it.
- When we say, like, support
an artist, we probably
mean, in some way, buying
the song, going to a concert,
I would continue to
purchase Michael Jackson
songs on iTunes.
I feel a little weird
about that sometimes.
- But was he convicted?
- He wasn't though.
- Exactly.
That's the weird part, right?
It's like, because someone
with so power and so much
influence, but then again,
he could be someone who
did something so horribly wrong.
- If you're trying to
debate with yourself,
whether or not, to
like, go see that movie,
or like, go see that artist
that you know did something,
then are you background
checking every artist
that you support?
- All situations are totally different,
and then again, I don't
have like, the facts
on the Nate Parker story.
Something terrible happened for sure.
- Is there an artist that
you can think of that's
done something that, in your opinion,
you still feel okay supporting their work?
- I saw The Pianist that Polansky did.
- Yeah.
- Didn't know Polanksy
did the things he did.
Right, it's like, man,
that's a horrible person.
The Pianist was a dope film.
- And like, here's the
thing though, for me,
is that like, it's one
thing if you're not aware
of someone doing something terrible,
and you've already supported the art,
that's one thing.
But it's hard for me to
consciously know what has
happened, and then still
feel like I can support that.
- You wanna see some remorse.
Like Roman Polansky, emailed
his victim years later,
and apologized.
- I wonder how much more
comfortable I would be
going to see it if he
just spoke more openly
and sensitively about it.
- I think that, especially
as a black person,
it's really hard, cause
I feel like at the end
of the day, when it's a black figure,
I'm forced to choose between my blackness,
or like, supporting a fucked up thing.
- When Tyra Banks was like,
"we were all rooting for you!"
Like, that's how I felt.
- Yes, I feel that!
(extreme crosstalk)
- That's how I felt, I was just like, no!
Are you kidding me?
We were all rooting for you,
and the thing about it is,
I was so ready, I was like, yes!
People are excited about
it because it's educational
and it's about black folk,
who are unapologetic,
and that's something that we need today.
But then, this came up, and
I'm like, there's no way
that I can support this.
- I felt this way about
Straight Outta Compton, too,
like, you know, I was so
here for it, especially
as someone who loves hip
hop, and then to find
out about all the Dr.
Dre and the woman beating
things, and the casting
call, and I was like,
I can't, I can't give you my money,
because again, money is power.
- There also needs to be more grey.
It was actually a really
wise thing that Daysha said.
I was like telling her
that I was really upset
about something Beyonce
did, I felt bad about that,
because I still like
Beyonce, and Daysha was like,
"You can like her as an
artist, and a person,
"and not be okay with
everything that she does."
- It's hard too, because
like, his one terrible
mistake is a reflection upon everybody who
was a part of the film.
So like, people are choosing
not to see it, like me.
I'm well aware that I am
not supporting the cast,
the crew, you know, everyone else.
And a part of me is like,
damn that sucks, because,
I want, yeah, like I love Gabrielle Union.
You know, I'm sure the
crew worked hard, they were
like, you know, this was a long journey.
- You can always argue
that you going to see
the movie doesn't make
that much of a difference,
but it's just that much more admirable,
to take your own personal
stand against it.
- I'm gonna go see the film.
What I can take away
from this is learn from
the situation.
- I mean, I think it's a
pretty fucked situation.
- Yeah.
- I think that Birth of
a Nation is gonna be an
incredibly important
film, and I think that
it's really fucked that
it's entrenched in this,
in this tragedy.
- Are you gonna see it?
- I'm gonna Netflix it.
- I love how we act like
that's really sticking
it to them.
- I am.
I'm gonna Netflix that movie!
(laughing)
I can't separate art from artists.
- Yeah.
I can't either.
I think that I'm not gonna see the movie.
I can't.
I'm not gonna Netflix
it, I'm not gonna give
my money to it.
- You know that if tomorrow, if tomorrow
every guy who was ever charged with being
an asshole, and woman,
people stop supporting their art,
you know people would take a lot more,
they would think a lot
more before they did stuff.
- I think this has definitely taught me
to look into people, and who they are,
before I support them.
Kwesi, thanks for joining us today!
Yeah!
(applause)
Alright guys, so you know what to do,
leave your comments below,
and we'll see you next week.
(downbeat electronic music)
(screech of dry erase marker)